WITH THE MIKE WELCOME EVERYONE
LET ME GO AHEAD AND CALL THEM A
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY TWELFTH
MEETING OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
TO ORDER- MADAM SECRETARY WILL
YOU CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
BASS. BAITS HERE MONNING HERE
MONNING HERE OFFICER HERE WILK
WILK HERE. HERE IS HERE. THANK
YOU I WILL GO A AND SEE IF
BEFORE WE CALL THEGOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
OF IF WE CAN. DO A CONSENT
CALENDAR AGENDA WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE IS NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR WE HAVE DE
THROUGH BY. ANYONE WISH TO PULL
ANY OF THOSE SEPARATE THEM OUT
OKAY- SO ITEM TWO DE THROUGH
I'D- ITEM THREE REFERRAL OF
BILLS ITEM FOR RULE WAIVER
REQUEST. ITEM FIVE FLOOR
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS IT WOULD
ACTUALLY BE ITEM FIVE THROUGH
TWELVE. I'D BE HAPPY AS I
COLLEAGUES LOOK TO. THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES. BATES AYE
MONNING MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH I
WILL COMBINE WILK AYE ATKINS HI
A CONCISE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES AND WITH THAT WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND CALL THE
FIRST- OUR APPOINTMENT FORWARD
MISS PATRICIA MONAGHAN MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. AND. ASK THAT I YOU
TAKE YOUR A FEW MINUTES AND-
OPENING COMMENTS IF YOU WANNA
THANK ANYONE FOR JOINING YOU
HERE TODAY AND THEN WE'LL GO
RIGHT INTO QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS WELCOME THANK YOU WELL
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
FAMILY- WHICH IT'S A REAL
PLEASURE TO HAVE MY FAMILY AT A
WORK EVENTS WHICH IS SO RARE
SO- MY HUSBAND LARRY MILLER
WHO'S A PSYCHOLOGIST OF MY
YOUNGER DAUGHTER NAOMI. HIS
FAMILY FRIEND TRISTEN. AND THE
MY OLDER DAUGHTER GILLIAN- AND
IT REALLY IS A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE TODAY AND- I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS AND
OUR DISCUSSION- THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME A FEW MINUTES TO
ADDRESS YOU BEFORE WE DIVE INTO
THE DISCUSSION- I WANT TO SAY
FIRST OFF THAT- YESTERDAY WAS
THE INTERNATIONAL DAY OF WOMEN.
AND GIRLS IN SCIENCE- SO I
THINK IT'S A PARTICULARLY
AUSPICIOUS DAY TO BE HAVING
THIS HEARING- AND- I AM IN THE
SIGNED TO SLOT AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND I'M THE FIRST
WOMAN SCIENTISTS IN HISTORY OF
THE ENERGY COMMISSION. AND WITH
MY APPOINTMENT IT'S THE FIRST
TIME THERE HAS BEEN A MAJORITY
OF WOMEN ON THE COMMISSION
LEVEL AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION
SO. A LOT OF REASONS I THINK
FOR CELEBRATION- I THINK WE'RE
ALL WORKING TOWARDS. HAVING
GOVERNMENT REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE AND IT'S
WONDERFUL TO BE AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AT THE TIME IN OUR
INTERNET. THREE SO I HAVE
PRETTY MUCH MY- PROFESSIONAL.
WORKING TO REDUCE HARMFUL AIR
POLLUTION AND TO ACCELERATE A
CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY WITH A
STRONG FOCUS ON TRANSPORTATION.
MY PRIMARY GOAL AS A
COMMISSIONER IS TO ADVANCE
CLEAN SAFE AFFORDABLE ENERGY AS
WE WORK TO MEET OUR STATE GOALS
FOR CLIMATE AND CLEAN ENERGY.
THIS INCLUDES HAVING 1100%
CLEAN ELECTRICITY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE AS MANDATED BY- SB
ONE HUNDRED AS A LEAD AGENCY
ELLIS ENERGY AGENCY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION IS GOING TO PLAY A
KEY ROLE IN COORDINATING WITH
OTHER AGENCIES AND MAKING SURE
WE HAVE THE ANALYTICAL
UNDERPINNINGS TO BE ABLE TO
REACH THAT GOAL AS I SAID. THIS
IS TRANSPORTATION AND THAT IS
REALLY WHAT DREW ME TO THIS
THIS POSITION- AS YOU PROBABLY
KNOW WE ARE- TRANSPORTATION IS
THE NUMBER ONE SOURCE OF GLOBAL
WARMING POLLUTION IN THE STATE.
IT'S NUMBER ONE SOURCE OF TOXIC
DIESEL POLLUTION IS THE NUMBER
ONE SOURCE OF SMOG FORMING
NITROGEN OXIDES. AND IT'S GOING
THE WRONG DIRECTION SO IN TERMS
OF OUR GLOBAL WARMING POLLUTION
WELL WE'VE CUT. ELECTRICITY
MISSIONS ABOUT IN HALF OVER THE
LAST TWO DECADES. WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS AN INCREASE IN
TRANSPORTATION POLLUTION OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS. AND
THAT'S WORRISOME- AS THE POINT
PERSON FOR THE COMMISSION FOR
TRAIN ON THE COMMISSION FOR
TRANSPORTATION MY GOAL IS TO
HELP THE STATE REACH ITS GOALS
FOR TRANSPORTATION INCLUDING
HAVING ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON THE ROAD
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AND
HAVING FIVE MILLION ON THE ROAD
BY TWENTY THIRTY. OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IS IN THE
MIDST OF WHAT DANCE FOR ONLY A
UC DAVIS CALLS REVOLUTIONARY
CHANGE BASICALLY THIS
COMBINATION OF ELECTRIFICATION
AUTOMATION AND MOBILITY AS A
SERVICE. AND A LOT OF THE
COMPANIES THAT ARE WORKING ON
THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA IS
BASICALLY THE NEW MICHIGAN WHEN
IT COMES TO WHAT I WOULD CALL
NEW MOBILITY. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HARNESS THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND SOCIAL TRENDS
FOR THE GOOD. AND THAT WE
INCREASE MOBILITY FOR ALL.
LOWER COSTS ESPECIALLY FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN REACH OUR
CLIMATE AND ENERGY GOALS. WE
ALSO NEED TO DIVERSIFY OUR
SUITE OF TRANSPORTATION FUELS
BEYOND FOSSIL FUELS. TO INCLUDE
LOW AND ZERO CARBON FUELS LIKE-
WHY MENTION ELECTRICITY
HYDROGEN. AND ALSO SUSTAINABLE
BIOFUELS. LASTLY I WANT TO JUST
EMPHASIZE I HAVE A DEEP
COMMITMENT TO EQUITY AND TO
MAKING SURE THAT NOBODY GETS
LEFT BEHIND WHEN WE HARNESS THE
THREE REVOLUTIONS IN THIS
TRANSPORTATION WORLD. ARE I
THINK WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYBODY BENEFITS- NOT JUST
WEALTHY PEOPLE. SO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
OPENING REMARKS A LOOK FORWARD
TO OUR DISCUSSION. YOUR FAMILY
SENATOR OFF YOU WANNA KICK US
OFF. CERTAINLY THANK YOU MAYOR
PRO TEM- COMMISSIONER A
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
EMPLOYMENT IN YOUR CONTINUED
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE THANK YOU
I'M- FROM INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE A GOOD
NUMBER OF FOLKS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA WHO COMMUTE LONG
DISTANCES BECAUSE WE BUILD
HOUSES OUT WHERE I AM AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE JOBS TEND TO
BE ON THE URBAN IN YOUR BEEN
COASTAL AREAS. AND GIVEN THE.
GIVEN THE I WOULD SAY
DIFFICULTY ASSOCIATED WITH
BUILDING A CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR UP IN A
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN
THE AFFORDABILITY OF VEHICLES-
WHAT LEVEL OF SUPPORT EXISTS AT
THE AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION
FOR THE- DEVELOPMENT. OF
HYDROGEN PASSENGER VEHICLES IS
SUPPOSED TO HYDROGEN MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES. SO THERE
ARE YOU PROBABLY DO KNOW THE
SERVER BUT THERE THERE'S TWO
TYPES OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE
BOTH ELECTRIC I WOULD SAY. THEY
BOTH HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY. AND
WHILE BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE MANY MORE
THAN NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT
GLOBALLY. SO CALIFORNIA HAS
OVER SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND. BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES- LIGHT DUTY BATTERY
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WE ALSO HAVE
ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND LIGHT DUTY
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES-
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING. THE WORLD
IN TERMS OF FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT. AND THERE
ARE SOME ADVANTAGES TO FUEL
CELLS BUT THERE ARE ALSO SOME
BIG HURDLES THAT WERE WERE
TRYING TO ADDRESS. THE
ADVANTAGES ARE THAT YOU CAN
HAVE QUICK REFUELLING BASICALLY
THE SAME AS THE INTERNAL
COMBUSTION VEHICLE AND YOU CAN
GO LONG DISTANCES THE
DISADVANTAGES WE DON'T HAVE OF.
A ROBUST NETWORK THAT IS AS
CONVENIENT AS YOUR BRIEF
REFUELING STATION SO WE'RE
BUILDING OUT THAT THEIR
EDUCATION IS THE LEAD FOR
BUILDING OUT HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE HAVE ABOUT
FORTY FUEL CELL- HYDROGEN
REFUELING STATIONS NOW IN THE
STATE WE HAVE ABOUT SIXTY FIVE
THAT ARE FUNDED AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO FUNDING UNTIL WE
HAVE A HUNDRED STATIONS.
OPERATIONAL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WILL SAY THAT ON
HEAVY DUTY. I THINK IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED
HEAVY DUTY FUEL CELL VEHICLES
TO BE ABLE TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
GOALS- THERE CERTAIN DUTY
CYCLES THAT ARE BETTER FOR FUEL
CELLS. AND WE'RE SEEING SOME
INVESTMENT IN THAT SPACE BUT
NOT ENOUGH I'M I'M VERY
COMMITTED TO- ENSURING THAT AS
WE MOVE FORWARD IN CALIFORNIA
WE ARE. ACTIVATING OTHER
COUNTRIES TO FOLLOW SUIT WE
CAN'T DO IT ALONE WE CAN'T
BUILD GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAINS
WITHOUT OTHER NATIONS REALLY
STEPPING UP AND BRINGING DOWN
THE PRICE OF FUEL CELLS. WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING THE PRICE OF
BATTERIES. CLIMATE PRESS THE
BATTERIES IS GUNNED DOWN 90% IN
THE LAST TEN YEARS IF IT
CONTINUES IN THE NEXT FIVE TO
TEN YEARS. THESE VEHICLES WILL
BE CHEAPER TO OWN. TO CHEAPER
TO BUY RATHER THERE ALREADY TWO
FOR TWO FIVE FROM AN
OPERATIONAL PERSPECTIVE HIS
ELECTRICITY IS CHEAPER THAN.
THAN GASOLINE. BUT I WOULD SAY
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT CALIFORNIA FOSTER'S DE UM
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE ARE GOING
TO NEED FOR THE FUTURE AND WE
DO THIS IN A GLOBAL CONTEXT.
AND IS DO YOUR COMMENTS ADDRESS
BOTH THE COMMERCIAL USE.
HYDROGEN OF HYDROGEN COMMERCIAL
VEHICLES LIGHT MEDIUM OR HEAVY
AS WELL AS PASSENGER VEHICLES.
YEAH THE FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE'RE BUILDING OUT HIS
HISTORICALLY JUST BEEN FOR
PASSENGER FEELS VEHICLES WITH
EXT EXPANDED THIS YEAR. TO
INCLUDE- HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
THEY ACTUALLY OF A DIFFERENT
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT FOR TECHNICAL
REQUIREMENTS AND ALSO AT IF YOU
OWN. A PASSENGER VEHICLE YOU
DON'T WANT TO BRIEF YOU DON'T
WANNA REVEAL NEXT TO A BIG LIKE
CLASS EIGHT TRUCK SO THERE'S
SOME JUST PHYSICAL CONSTRAINTS
TO HAVING THE TO- IN THE SAME
LOCATION. BUT THOSE ARE THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT WERE WORKING ON
WE ARE DEFINITELY YOU KNOW OUR-
GOAL IS TO USE OUR FUNDS AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO. EXPAND OUT
TO THE HEAVY MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY SECTOR WHERE WE REALLY SEE
A NEED. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MATTER TO MODE FOR THE MOVIE A
CONFIRMATION. YOU THANK YOU BYE
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU AYE MAN PUT
I A YES IN A CAN GROW ON
APPOINT. WE HAD CONVERSATION ON
THAT SIGN IS ONE OF TO TALK TO
WHICH IS BUT THE MAYBE MAYBE
TOUCH ON HOW. YOU SEE IS BEING
ABLE TO BALANCE CONSERVING
RESOURCES AND PROTECTING THE
ENVIRONMENT WITH HAVING A
SECURE RELIABLE MULTI FACETED
ENERGY SOURCES JUST KIND OF
MAYBE. YOUR VIEW ON HOW WE
CHECK ALL THAT. YES WELL LET ME
START IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SPACE THAT I KNOW THE BEST IF
YOU WANT WOULD LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT THE ELECTRICITY CITING
HAPPY IT TO TALK ABOUT THAT AS
WELL. SO AS WE INVEST IN
CLEANER TRANSPORTATION AND AS
WE THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE
CAPITALIZE ON THE OPPORTUNITY
TO- TO REDUCE COSTS. WE NEED TO
REALLY THINK THROUGH- WITH
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN
PARTICULAR HOW TO OPTIMIZE THE
CONNECTION OF THESE VEHICLES TO
THE GRID BECAUSE IF YOU. CHARGE
VEHICLES AT THE RIGHT TIME OF
DAY THEY PROVIDE A GREAT VALUE.
IT ONE OF MY FAVORITE LITTLE
DATA POINTS IS THAT WE COULD
HAVE CHARGED EVERYONE OF OUR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES EVERYONE OF
OUR LIKE TO THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. WITH THE AMOUNT OF
ENERGY THAT WE CURTAILED IN THE
MONTH OF MAY BECAUSE WE WERE
GENERATING. RENEWABLE ENERGY AT
A TIME WHEN WE COULDN'T USE AT
ALL. SO IF WE HAVE THIS HAPPY
MARRIAGE THAN WHAT IT RESULTS
IN IS LOWER COSTS FOR EVERYBODY
I THINK ELECTRIFICATION IN
GENERAL THERE'S A LOT OF DATA
THAT WOULD INDICATE THAT IF
WE'RE SUCCESSFUL- EVERYBODY
BENEFITS. BECAUSE THE VEHICLES
AND THE FUELS ARE. GOING TO BE
CHEAPER AND THAT MONEY STAYS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA INSTEAD OF
BEING SENT OUT OF THE STATE. SO
IF WE ARE SUCCESSFUL IN
ELECTRIFYING LIGHT DUTY
TRANSPORTATION. THAT SHOULD BE
IT A GAME CHANGER NGUYEN IN
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF MONEY
SAVED AT THE PUMP. MONEY
RECIRCULATING THROUGH OUR
ECONOMY AND JOBS HERE IN THE
STATE. I ALSO THINK AS WE AS
WE- THINK ABOUT EQUITY- I. I
WOULD SAY WE NEED TO THINK ALSO
ABOUT HOW DO WE ENGAGE. GROUPS
THAT CAN ADVISE US. BECAUSE I
CAN SAY COMING FROM A
SCIENTIFIC WORLD YOU DON'T
NECESSARILY DO SCIENCE THAT IS
APPLICABLE TO THE REAL WORLD
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYTHING WE DO. IS GROUNDED
IN SOME KIND OF. UNITY BENEFIT
THE WE CAN ARE TO. AND THAT WE
CAN MEASURE. HISTORICALLY WE'VE
MEASURED FROM OUR INVESTMENTS
IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND ATTENTIVENESS IT'S JUST
LIKE WELL HOW MUCH MONEY ARE WE
SPENDING IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. SO WE'VE REACHED
OUT TO THE DISADVANTAGED VIEWS
ADVISORY GROUP AND ASK THEM FOR
LIKE WHAT WHAT ELSE CAN WE DO
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE METRIC BUT
THAT'S NOT. ALL YOU KNOW THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THERE ARE JOBS
CREATED THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THEY'RE HEALTH BENEFITS THAT
DOESN'T MEAN. COMMUNITIES ARE
DIRECTLY BENEFITING SO HOW DO
WE DO HOW DO WE ENGAGE THE
RIGHT PARTNERS WHO HELP ADVISE
US SO THAT WE CAN DEVELOP
CRITERIA. THAT IS JUST SORT OF
A BIT MORE COMPLICATED A AND
GIVES US MORE CONFIDENCE THAT
WE ARE REALLY USING OUR MONEY
IN A WAY THAT PROMOTES
EQUITABLE TRANSPORTATION. RATE
AS THANK YOU FOR THAT ANSWER
AND LOOKING TO- VOTING ICE ON
YOUR CONFIRMATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I ALSO WANT TO
OFFER MY CONGRATULATIONS AND-
YOU'RE MAKING THE REFERENCES TO
THE- WOMEN IN SCIENCE
RECOGNITION AND ALSO THE-
CRITICAL MASS THAT'S BEEN
ACHIEVED ON THE COMMISSION- I
WANT TO PICK UP A LITTLE BIT ON
THE EQUITY PIECE- RELATED TO.
ELECTRIFICATION OF
TRANSPORTATION- WHEN WE TALKED
YESTERDAY. HE SHARED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT COLLABORATION WITH
CARB IN IF YOU COULD SHARE THAT
WITH THE COMMITTEE IN. WERE
AHEAD OF SCHEDULE ON A
RENEWABLE ENERGY WE'RE BEHIND
ON OUR TRANSPORTATION OBJECTIVE
SO WE'RE KIND OF PLAYING CATCH
UP TO ADDRESS SOME OF THAT. ON
THE EQUITY PIECE AS WELL THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT WE HAVE
FARMWORKERS COMMUTING FROM KING
CITY TO WATSONVILLE TO HARVEST
STRAWBERRIES IN THAT. HOUR AND
A HALF ONE WINNIE COMMUTE ON.
AND IN OLDER VEHICLES NOT
ENERGY EFFICIENT- HAD IS THAT
POPULATION TRANSITION. TWO MORE
FUEL EFFICIENT OR ELECTRICAL
VEHICLES THANK YOU CENTER
THAT'S THE THOSE ARE GOOD
QUESTIONS SO LET ME START WITH
THE COLLABORATIVE PIECE AND
THEN- TALK ABOUT WHAT WE DO
WITH- WITH FOLKS THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY CHOICE BUT TO USE
OLDER VEHICLES TO GET TO AND
FROM WORK- SO ON THE
COLLABORATION PIECE- I AM I AM
DEEPLY COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE REALLY CLOSELY
COLLABORATING ESPECIALLY WITH
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD BUT
ALSO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR- CALTRANS WE HAVE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT PARTNERS WERE
ENGAGED IN CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
AND WE WANT TO BE STRATEGIC-
WITH THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD I
TESTIFIED AT A RECENT RESOURCES
BOARD HEARING. BOARD MEETING
THAT. ARE FUNDING CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION GOING TO BE
INCREASINGLY FOCUSED ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FUEL SIDE.
AS A R. B. IS INCREASINGLY- YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THE PREMIER AGENCY
WHEN IT COMES TO VEHICLES SO IT
MAKES SENSE FOR THEM TO ALSO
LEAD IN THAT SPACE. WE ARE THE
PREMIER ENERGY IT THE- COMMA
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE
INDUSTRIES ARE AGENCY IN THE
STATE AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT AS WE- THAT WE
pTO BE BENEFICIAL TO. OUR ENERGY
GOALS AND ESPECIALLY TO OUR
1100% CLEAN ELECTRICITY COOL BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE SO IT MAKES
SENSE FOR THE ENERGY COMMISSION
TO FOCUS MORE ON INFRASTRUCTURE
SO THAT WOULD BE- WHETHER THAT
THAT'S THE BUILD OUT OF
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL A
INFRASTRUCTURE THE BUILD OUT OF
REACH CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
THE INVESTMENTS IN- NEAR UP
NEAR ZERO AND ZERO MISSION
FUELS TO HELP WITH VEHICLES
THAT ESPECIALLY THE ONES THAT
CAN BE EASILY ELECTRIFIED
THEY'RE STILL IN NEED TO
ADDRESS THOSE VEHICLES- AND
ADDRESS EMISSIONS FROM THOSE
VEHICLES SO I EIGHT I FEEL THAT
WE ARE GETTING MORE CLARITY
BETWEEN EXPECTED THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD AND THE ENERGY
COMMISSION ABOUT WHAT OUR RULES
ARE AND WE'RE AND WE'RE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE ARE MAXIMIZING OUR UTILITY
OF STATE DOLLARS IN TERMS OF
HOW DO WE DEAL WITH. WE
CHALLENGES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OR A PLACES WHERE FOR.
ARE NEED TO. ARTS CENTER COAST
WHERE FOLKS NEED TO GET TO WORK
THEY ONLY HAVE OLDER VEHICLES
THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
MOBILITY OPTIONS BUT I WOULD
SAY IS THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE-
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING- A SHIFT
IN THE A REGULATORY. THE
REGULATIONS AROUND TRANSIT
BUSES SO THOSE HAVE TO BE
ELECTRIC. AND THE THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY I THINK TO- TO
FOCUS MORE OF OUR ATTENTION ON
LAST MILE BETWEEN. BETWEEN THE
WHERE THE BUS DROPS YOU OFF AND
WHERE YOU NEED TO GET TO AGAIN
THIS NEED TO BE A COLLABORATION
WITH THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD-
BECAUSE THERE'S A- THERE'S A
VEHICLES COMPONENT TO THAT. BUT
WE'RE THINKING THROUGH MORE SO
HOW DO WE OPTIMIZE WHERE WE PUT
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT
WE CAN. INSURE IT SMACKS ME TO
LEAVE IT ALSO THAT IT COULD
SUPPORT POTENTIALLY THIS LAST
FILE- I DO THINK THOUGH WE WILL
NEED TO CAN TO FOCUS ON. YOU
KNOW THIS THERE'S A ROLE FOR
NATURAL GAS. AND ESPECIALLY
WHERE WE CAN'T EASILY ELECTRIFY
THERE'S A ROLE FOR. FOR FUELS
THAT ARE LOWER IN CARBON. EVEN
IF THEY'RE STILL YOU KNOW
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THE LEGACY FLEET. AND AGAIN I
THINK THE CHALLENGE BECAUSE BY
POVERTY MAKES TRANSITIONING.
LOW INCOME WORKERS ARE PART
TIME WORKERS TO HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES THAT OTHERS DO.
IN THE FARM LABOR SETTING- SOME
FARM LABOR CONTRACTORS
EMPLOYERS TO RELY ON BUSES AND
WE'RE CONVERTING FLEETS IN
AIRPORTS FOR A RENTAL. CAR
AGENCIES TO ELECTRIC- IN IT
MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT WE LOOK
TO. IN THE AGRICULTURAL ARENA
AS WELL THERE'S SOME GOOD
MODELS OUT THERE TOO I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU KNOW RAYLEóN
WHO'S THE MAYOR IF YOU'RE ON
YES AND HE'S BEEN. WORKING ON
HOW DO WE- BASICALLY
ELECTRIFIED VEHICLES THAT ARE
USED TO GET. FOLKS TO MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS AND TO WORK AND
HE'S DOING SOME REALLY
INNOVATIVE. OF WORK OUT THERE
SO I THINK THERE ARE SOME GOOD
EXAMPLES. AND WE NEED TO
REPLICATE AND- EXPAND YOU KNOW
THE NUMER OF EXAMPLES OUT
THERE OF WAYS THAT WE CAN HELP
EVERYBODY- GET ACCESS TO THESE
VEHICLES WILL THANK YOU AND
THEN JUST REAL QUICKLY IN A
TRANSPORTATION SHEER AREA OF
EXPERTISE WE TALKED A LITTLE OF
THAT. OFF WIND IN JUST MAKE.
SOME BRIEF. OF HOW YOU THINK
THAT FITS IN OUR FUTURE AND-
ACHIEVING CLEAN. RENEWABLE
ENERGY GOAL HAPPY TO WELL THE
ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING TO MEET.
OUR GOAL OF HAVING A 1100%
CLEAN GRID BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
IS TO HAVE A VERY DIVERSE SET
OF RESOURCES THAT WERE USING.
TO GENERATE ELECTRICITY. WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THE CONCEPT OF
OFF SURE WELL AFTER WIN BECAUSE
IT COMPLIMENTS SOLAR IT
COMPLIMENTS OF WINDS THAT
THAT'S DONE ON SHORE. THE AND
IT IT LOADS PRETTY MUCH ALL THE
TIME SO THERE'S JUST MORE IT IT
IN IN TERMS OF A RESOURCE THAT
WOULD BE A GREAT ADDITION TO
OUR TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
DIVERSE SET OF. SOURCES FOR
ELECTRICITY WE WOULD LOVE TO
CAPITALIZE ON THAT AS YOU WELL
KNOW THERE ARE SOME ISSUES.
WITH THE WITH THE NAVY THERE
SOME ISSUES WILL MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE DO THIS AN
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND WAY AND
OUR ROLE. HE HAS WITH THE WITH
THE CHAIR LEADING THIS AS AS
COMMISSIONER. TO PLAY CONVENING.
AND BRING THE PARTIES TOGETHER.
ENTER AND MAKE PROGRESS IN
TERMS OF. ENSURING THAT WE ARE.
GETTING THE KEY STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE ROOM AND SO THAT WE CAN.
IDENTIFY THE PROBLEMS AND
HOPEFULLY WORK THROUGH THEM.
THANK YOU AND I WANNA AGAIN.
CONGRATULATE YOU BUT ALSO THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR EXPERTISE
WITH THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR MINING
LET ME PICK UP ON THAT- AREA
THAT SENATOR MINING STARTED AND
JUST. PUSH A LITTLE FURTHER ON
THAT THE CONVENING. WHAT WOULD
YOU SAY THIS ISN'T REALLY THE
STATUS OF THE DELIBERATIONS AT
THIS POINT RELATED TO MOVING
FORWARD. WITH OFFSHORE WIND
WITH OFF SHORE WELL
INTERESTINGLY WE DECIDE
ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SAYING THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ISN'T
GOING TO BE APPROVING ANY
OFFSHORE WIND DEVELOPMENTS
UNTIL AFTER THE ELECTION SO.
THERE THERE IS- SOME YOU KNOW
JUST IN TERMS OF THE NATIONAL
POLITICS IT'S A LITTLE
COMPLICATED I WOULD SAY- AT
THEIR IT IT HAVE BASE. THE DO
YOU GOVERNMENT HAS TEARS PAST
THREE MILES SO WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE AN AGREMENT
THAT IS SATISFACTORY TO THE
NATIONAL GOVERNMENT ADDED OKAY
WELL SHOULD WE BE SUCCESSFUL AT
SOME POINT DO YOU THINK THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER
ESTABLISHING KIND OF A ONE STOP
SHOP KIND OF LIKE WE'VE DONE OR
THAT THE CDC IS DONE FOR
THERMAL POWER PLANTS. HAVE YOU
THOUGHT ABOUT. ON I HAVEN'T
WILL AT NOT THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
SO WE CAN. I CAN DELIVER IT
WITH OUR STAFF AND GET BACK TO
YOU ON THAT THANK YOU OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS. OF FORWARD THINKING IN
TERMS OF WHERE WE CAN GO SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THE LAST- I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES IT'S ALWAYS
GOOD TO GO LAST THEY ASK ALL
THE GOOD QUESTIONS- AND THE
IMPORTANT ONES BUT- I WANT TO
ASK ABOUT THE EPIC PROGRAM AND-
THE ROUGHLY A HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION THAT THE COMMISSION HAS
THE ABILITY. TWO WOULD PUT OUT
THE TO THE INTEREST. GROUPS ARE
OUR INVESTMENTS IN ENERGY
RESEARCH TO OUR CLEAN- TO CLEAN
OUR GRID- THESE ARE RATE PAYER
FUNDS- I THINK IN SOME RESPECTS
THERE'S VERY FEW THAT ACTUALLY
KNOW ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
INCLUDING PEOPLE IN THE
LEGISLATURE SO. HOW ARE THESE
FUNDS BEING SPENT RIGHT NOW AND
A AND MAYBE A LITTLE BIT HOW DO
YOU THINK THEY'RE SAVING RATE
PAYERS MONEY. WELL I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THE INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'RE MAKING- IN OUR
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
THROUGH EPIC DOLLARS. AND
THAT'S BECAUSE THAT IT'S REALLY
OPERATING AT THE CUTTING EDGE
OF YOU KNOW BEFORE A PRE
COMMERCIALIZED. PRODUCT IS
AVAILABLE THEY WERE TRYING TO
SUPPORT. THE PRODUCT
DEVELOPMENT FROM A VERY EARLY
STAGE SO THAT WE CAN CAPITALIZE
ON THOSE CLEAN ENERGY
TECHNOLOGIES. AGAIN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN AN ERA
OF WILDFIRES AND PUBLIC SAFETY
POWERSHOT US. RIGHT WE'RE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE
RIGHT INVESTMENTS IN
MICROGRAPHS. BOGGLING FOR IT
READ RANCHERIA IS A REALLY GOOD
EXAMPLE OF AN INVESTMENT THAT
WE SUPPORTED. YOU KNOW THEY- IN
THE LAST. THE SORT OF FIRES IN
THIS LAST YEAR. THEY REPORTED
THAT 10% OF ALL HUMBOLDT
RESIDENTS. USE THE SERVICES AT
THE RENTERIA. AND THAT THEY
SAVED FOR LIVES. THOSE ARE THE
KINDS OF INVESTMENTS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE. WE CONTINUE TO MAKE.
TO SUPPORT A MORE RESILIENT
ENERGY SYSTEM- WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT TECHNOLOGIES THAT
CAN ISLAND HOMES SO THAT YOU
CAN WITH THE POWER SHUT OFF TO
YOU CAN STILL USE YOUR- SOLAR
AND YOU CAN. CONTINUE TO USE
ELECTRICITY- BUT THE THIS IS IN
MY MIND AWAY THAT CALIFORNIA IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO STAY. AT AT
IN A LEADERSHIP ROLE NOT JUST
HERE IN UNITED STATES BUT
GLOBALLY. ON. CLEAN ENERGY IT
CLEAN ELECTRICITY TECHNO. JEEZ
THAT HELP US MAKE SURE WE CAN
REACH OUR GOAL. WERE EVEN USING
EPIC DAHLE. TO INVEST IN SOME.
ADVOCATE AS A NOTED BEFORE. AT
IF WE DO IT RIGHT SAVE MONEY WE
SAVE ALL. CONSUMERS WE WANT TO
DO A RIGHT AND WE WANT TO MAKE
THE RIGHT INVESTMENTS SO THAT
WE CAN CAPITALIZE ON THIS
VEHICLE TO GRID. INTEGRATION WE
FUNDED OVER TWO HUNDRED SCHOOL
BUSES THAT ARE ELECTRIC AND
THEY HAVE THE POTENTIAL NOT
JUST TO ACTUALLY GIVE
ELECTRICITY BACK TO THE GRID IS
CALLED VGA OR VEHICLE TO GRID.
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT USING SOME
OF OUR EPIC DOLLARS TO
CAPITALIZE ON THE POTENTIAL TO
DO DEMONSTRATION ABOUT WHAT HOW
DO WE HOW DO WE ACTUALLY DO
THIS. HOW DO WE USE SCHOOL
BUSES AS A RESOURCE WHEN THE
GRID GET GOES DOWN. AND SCHOOL
BUSES ARE PARTICULARLY ENTICING
BECAUSE THEY'RE CHARGED- YOU
KNOW THEY CAN BE CHARGING
MIDDLE DAY WHEN WE HAVE A LOT
OF RENEWABLE ENERGY PRODUCTION.
THEY ALSO ARE NOT USED AS MUCH
IN THE SUMMER WHEN WE ACTUALLY
NEED THOSE RESILIENCE SERVICES.
SO THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT WE'RE INVESTING
IN WITH OUR EPIC RESEARCH
DOLLARS. VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NOW I THINK WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLICWHO ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
LET ME ASK- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE IN SUPPORT
IF YOU WOULD COME FORWARD- I
WILL ASK YOU TO BE BRIEF- A
GIVE YOUR NAME WHO YOU'RE WITH
AND IF YOU SUPPORT A YOU KNOW.
THE NOMINEES SO I. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MANY
DISCOUNT LEACOCK ON THIS YEAR
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AND PUBLIC POLICY FOR
PRO TERRA. LEADING TRANSIT ALL
ELECTRIC BUSES MANUFACTURED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. COMMISSIONER
MONAHANS REAPPOINTMENT TO THE
FOR HER PRIOR BACKGROUND AS A
TRANSPORTATION EXPERT AT THE OF
THE ENERGY FOUNDATION AND THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
REALLY GIVE US CONFIDENCE THAT
SHE IS THE RIGHT PERSON. TO
LEAD THAT DIVISION INTO THE
FUTURE- SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
HER NOMINATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR IS BILL WOULD WITH
A CO FOR CORE AIR TO OF
COMMISSIONER MONAHANS
CONFIRMATION I THINK YOU'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SEE YOU TODAY WHY
SHE'S SUCH A GREAT CHOICE TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAWS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED TO CLEAN
UP OUR ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS. AND WE
ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE HER
DEMONSTRATE A COMMITMENT TO
EQUITY IN CLEAN MOBILITY AND
CLEAN ENERGY. THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS MY NAME IS
ABOUT TO ALIGN THE YEAR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICER. AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
SACRAMENTO METRO AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND WE ARE
HERE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
COMMISSION AND MONAGHAN. WE IN
SACRAMENTO ARE TRYING TO BE A
TEST BED FOR FUTURE MOBILITY
AND SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
ENERGY AND WE'RE JUST EXCITED
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE. THE
LEADERSHIP OF COMMISSIONER
MONAGHAN AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION BECAUSE WE HAVE A
LONG WAYS TO GO AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HI WHY GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS TERESA COOK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
COALITION VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT- COMMISSIONER MONAHANS
APPOINTMENT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO THE FUEL
CELL DISCUSS. AN FOR VEHICLE
THANK YOU MUCH BUT I AT CERTAIN
THAT I'M TWO THOUSAND NINE WE
WERE BEGINNING AND- ABOUT TO
RENEW PART. STANDARD AND
SACRAMENTO WHAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED IF WE WOULD HAVE HAD A
SOLAR ONLY OF STRAW AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY IN. THAT WE ARE
PUTTING. A THE- BUT PACKED
THESE ARE ON TWO TECHNO. YOU
KNOW TWELVE SO WE CAN SURE EVER
DRIVER CAL. HAS THE- OF AND AS
CAN BE A- THANK. SORRY I
ACTUALLY STARTED IN SUPPORT OF
THE GRIEF HAVE IT TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE AND COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT I'M WERE ALL
MEMBERS OF AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED CHARTER HAD CALIFORNIA-
WHICH AIMS TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES I'M
AND ABILITY AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND WAS MONEY HAS A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF REALLY
ADVANCING EQUITY CLASS AND OUR
CLIMATE AND CLEAN OUT THE GOALS
ADAM AND WE'RE DELIGHTED TO BE
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AFTER CARRILLO
SOMEHOW OF THE LECTURE VEHICLE
TO. SO I REALLY JUST WANT TO
SECOND MANY OF THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY THE-
MY COLLEAGUES AND I WOULD JUST
ADD THAT. REALLY SUPPORT
APPRECIATE COMMISSIONER MY
HANDS COMMENTS ON FOCUSING ON
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WE KNOW THAT'S CAN
BE A VERY VERY CRITICAL ASPECT.
OF ACCOMPLISHING OUR GHG ENDS
OF DEPLOYMENT GOALS SO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR OF THE SENATORS BY NAMES
OUT OF MY HOBBY HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE V. GO. AS THE
NATION'S LARGEST AND MOST
RELIABLE NETWORK OF PUBLIC
ELECTRIC VEHICLE FAST CHARGING-
WE'VE WORKED FIRSTHAND WITH
MICHELLE MONAGHAN AND KNOW THAT
SHE HAD KNOWS THE- THE POLICIES
THE STAKEHOLDERS. MECHANISMS TO
REALLY ARE SURE AND IN THE ERA
OF CREEK TRAIL. FOR BUT
RELIABLE E. I REALLY EQUITABLE
FROM CALIFORNIANS SO WE ARE TO
SUPPORT TODAY THANKS. THANK YOU.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I AM AND THE
OLSEN HERE HAVE ENTERED ECONOMY
ECHO A LOT OF THE SENT TO.
ALREADY INTEREST. STAND PROUDLY
AND- OF COMMISSIONER. REPLAY
MAY TO THIS. I WANT TO THANK
YOU SO FOR HER STATE.
LEADERSHIP KEEPING CALIFORNIA
THE FOREFRONT OF OUR INNOVATIVE
CLEAN TRANSPORT ECONOMY. THANK
YOU. I WELCOME. HELLO MY NAME
IS CHRISTIAN CORBY AND I'M THE
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION-
EILEEN TIED OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR- WASN'T ABLE TO BE
HERE TODAY- BUT SHE WISHED TO
BE HERE BECAUSE SHE WANTED TO-
EMPHATICALLY ENDORSE A MISS
MONAHANS REEMPLOYMENT. TO THE-
ENERGY COMMISSION THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HI WELCOME
CATHERINE PHILLIPS WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA WE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY ENDORSE PATTY
FOR THIS POSITION AND ALL THE
GOOD THINGS THEY SAID WE AGREE
WITH. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
JOHN WHITE FROM THE CENTER FOR
THE DEFICIENCY RENEWAL
TECHNOLOGIES IT'S BEEN MY GREAT
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH
COMMISSION MONAGHAN OVER MANY
MANY YEARS SHE WAS THERE AT THE
BEGINNING OF OUR PUSH FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AS AN
ADVOCATE. SHE'S GOING ON TO A
SUCCESSFUL CAREERIN
PHILANTHROPY AND A WE REALLY
APPRECIATE HER BEING AT THE
COMMISSION RIGHT NOW GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE. ON A
LECTOR TRANSPORTATION AND THE
NEED FOR A DIVERSE PORTFOLIO
AND PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AS- A
PRIVATE SECTOR SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER AND
HOPE THAT SHE CAN HELP LEAD THE
MINISTRATION. INSIST UP THE
PARTS BECAUSE WILL BECOME AND
WE NEED TO DO BETTER AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR TO DOING THAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M QUE REDNER SUTTER
WITH ENVIRONMENT DEFENSE FUND
I'M VERY. PLEASED TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MONEY
CONFIRMATIONS OF THE ENERGY
COMMISSION EDF HAS WORKED WITH
MISS MONEY HIM FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND I'M TRANSPORTATION
AND QUALITY AND ENERGY ISSUES.
I MEAN SHE'S A NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED SCIENTIST IN
IMPROVING LEADER IN THIS FIELD.
WITH A DEEP COMMITMENT TO
EQUITY INCLUSION- SO WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTES ON HER
CONFIRMATION THANK THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON WILL BEAR WITH
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA ALSO SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT WE KNOW COMMISSIONER
MONAHANS DEDICATION TO
ACHIEVING CLEANER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MEREDITH ALEXANDER
WITH CAL START ON BEHALF OF OUR
OVER TWO HUNDRED FORTY MEMBERS
INCLUDING VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS
FEEL PRODUCERS CHARGING
COMPANIES. AND MANY MORE I'M
JUST SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF MISS MONAHANS CONFIRMATION
AND AGAIN AS MANY OTHERS HAVE
SAID WE ALSO HAVE A LONG
HISTORY. OF WORKING WITH MISS
MONAGHAN- WHEN SHE WAS AT UCS
AND ALSO THE ENERGY FOUNDATION.
AND WE'VE BEEN REALLY IMPRESSED
BY HER LEADERSHIP WITH THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
OVER THE PAST YEAR. PUTTING
TOGETHER A THOUGHTFUL AND
BALANCED INVESTMENT PORTFOLIO.
AND WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER AND FUTURE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
AYE AARON RODRIGUEZ WITH UNION
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND WE'RE
REALLY PROUD TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT. MISS MONAGHAN AND
WE'VE HAD A SURE WORKING WITH
HER THE YEAR AND SHE'S A ARDENT
SUPPORTER OF. EQUITY AND
TRANSPORTATION AND- STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANKS THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON LILLIAN
MARVIS WITH THE CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY I'M HERE
TODAY TO SHARE THAT WE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT
COMMISSIONER MONAHANS. NATION
TO THE TWENTY AND THE
COMMISSION. STRONG BACKGROUND.
AND THREE OKAY AS UNDER
COMMUNITIES AND- COMMUNITY.
WE'VE ENJOYED WORKING WITH HER
ON THE COUCH. VEHICLE AND AFTER
FOR. AND WE SHALL SUPPORT AND I
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU. GET
UP TO THE FAN ON HAVE THE COW.
EFFICIENCY DEMAND MANTRA
COUNCIL AND STRONG SO OF THE
COMMITTEE COME FROM. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DAN JACOBSON WITH AND
CAL VERY PROJECT. AND STAND IN
SO REALLY PRETTY REASONS AS THE
UTILITY STRUGGLE WITH WAYS TO
PROVIDE US THEY'RE GONNA CHANGE
IN THE NEXT TEN FIFTEEN YEARS.
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT PROGRAMS LIKE THE MILLION
SOLAR ROOFS PROGRAM AND SOLAR
MANDATE CONTINUES WE'RE GONNA
LOOK TO THE- COMMISSIONER IN
THE C. C. TO DO THAT. AS WE
LOOK TO OFFSHORE WIND I MEAN
GEEZ MODEST BUT SHE'S REALLY AN
EXPERT IN THAT ISSUE AND WE
NEED TO SEE YOU SEE TO CONTINUE
TO PUSH US ON THERE. AND OTHER
FUELS THAT ENSURE THAT WE CAN
GET THEIR CLEANLY FROM POINT A
TO POINT B. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE ATKINS
MEMBER DIRECTLY HEIDI SO
DIRECTOR OF ENERGY AND- WITH.
ON THE SO CALLED LEADERS GROUP
I'LL TRANCE. LOW TO VACATION
POLICY OF AND I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE WORKING WITH.
COMMISSIONER MONAGHAN OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS AND
TRANSPORTATION LECTURE CATION.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MEMBER COMPANIES
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF HER
REAPPOINTMENT. AND I CAN'T-
OVER EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF. HER WORK AND MEETING OR
TRANSPORTATION LECTURE KITCHEN
EFFORTS WHICH TOUCH THE LIVES
OF NEARLY EVERY CALIFORNIANS SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE MOVING
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES. MONNING MONNING
AYE ROTH ROSS I WILK WILK
ATKINS AYE ATKINS AM WILL LEAVE
THE WERE OPEN FORCE BATES WHEN
SHE WERE BUT YOU HAVE ENOUGH
VOTES YOU HAVE BEEN FOR A.
OKAY.
THANK YOU SIR RIGHT. YOU CAN
OPEN IT UP THEN I CALL. ANSWER
AND CLOSE THE- JUST TO BORDER
TO LAST ONE. I MEAN YOU. I KNOW
I ALMOST WAS GOOD. RIGHT NOW.
AN OPEN THE ROLE ON THIS- LAST
APPOINTMENT MADAM SECRETARY
SENATOR BATES. OKAY FOUR ZERO-
THE CONFIRMATION IS PAST FOUR
ZERO THANK YOU. THANKS CHRIS
SORRY I SHOULD THE. WELCOME.
I'LL LET PEOPLE COMMENTS WE CAN
HEAR YOU AND I'D TO THE
SERGEANTS. ADRIN CAN YOU THERE
WAS A TROUBLE HEARING AND
THEY'RE HOPING WE CAN TURN THE
MIKE UP A LITTLE BIT. THE
PUBLIC THE PUBLIC WHEN I THINK
MORE. THANK YOU ADRIAN SO OUT
WELCOME ON LET ME I INVITE YOU
TO INTRODUCE MEMBERS OF YOUR
FAMILY OR FRIENDS IT MIGHT BE
HERE TO SUPPORT YOU AT MAKE
SOME OPENING COMMENTS AND THEN
WE'LL GO INTO- QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS LET ME IN ADVANCE
APOLOGIZE I MAY HAVE TO LEAVE I
FULLY INTENDED TO VOTE IN
SUPPORT IF I'M STILL HERE I
WILL DO THAT BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOU KNEW- MY POSITION
BASED. ON THE READING AND OF
THE INFORMATION SO- PLEASE
FORGIVE ME MY STEPPING AWAY
WILL NOT HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH. A YOU WERE. NOT YES THANK
YOU THANK YOU I NEED WORDS IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE AN ATTORNEY IN THE
ROOM I HAVE SEVERAL WHO CAN
HELP ME HERE- SO WELCOME AND
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO INTRODUCE
YOUR FAMILY AND FRIENDS YES MY
FAMILY'S HERE- MY- HUSBAND
AARON- MY SON JAY. AND MY
DAUGHTER LILA. WELL COUNTY MISS
SCHOOL TODAY SO. WOW THAT I
LIKED YOUR EXPRESSION ON
MISSING SCHOOL TODAY BUT I BET.
I BET YOU GET AWAY WITH IT AND
YOU'RE JUST FINE IN YOUR
STUDIES YES. ALL THAT'S A
DELIGHT. HEY GOOD MORNING OR
GOOD EVERYBODY- AT THE GOOD
AFTERNOON TO US IN A PRO TEM
ATKINS AND OTHER SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY MY
NAME IS LYNN ANDERSON I AM
TRULY HAPPY TO BE HERE THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING THE
CONFIRMATION AS MY- FOR OF MY
APPOINTMENT AS CHIEF OF THE
BUREAU OF SECURITY
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES. I BRING
TO THIS POSITION OVER TWO
DECADES OF LEADERSHIP
EXPERIENCE I'VE WORKED BOTH ON
THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS
AND I HAVE RECENTLY SERVED OVER
FOURTEEN YEARS IN THIS
BUILDING. MY LENGTHY AN ONGOING
ROLE AS A PUBLIC SERVANT HAS
TAUGHT ME THE IMPORTANCE OF
QUICK FEDERAL INFLUX OF
REACTION TO MEDIC SITUATIONS
AND BEING RESPONSIVE TO ALL
SIDES OF AN ISSUE- I FIRMLY
BELIEVE IN STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT AND SEEN THE ART OF
THE POSSIBLE WHEN IT COMES TO
LEGISLATION. REGULATION AND
STATUTORY CHANGES. IT IS AN
HONOR TO BE ENTRUSTED WITH ONE
OF THE LARGEST LICENSING
BUREAUS IN CALIFORNIA. AND I AM
THRILLED TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
MY TEAM AT BY YES I GUESS THEY
DISPLAY EXCELLENCE ON A DAILY
BASIS THERE AND I'M LUCKY TO
HAVE THEM ON MY TEAM. I
PERSONALLY STRIVE EVERYDAY TO
ALSO ATTAIN EXCELLENCE AND TO
MAKE THE BUREAU EASIER FOR
CONSUMERS. CONSTITUENTS AND
LICENSEES TO NAVIGATE. I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND THE AND- OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ACTIVELY AND
AGGRESSIVELY PROTECT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. WILL MAKING OUR
PROCESS SEES EASIER. FOR OUR
LICENSEES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU MISS SANDERS FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO THE STATE
CONGRATULATIONS ON THIS
APPOINTMENT WELCOME TO YOUR
FAMILY- THESE ARE TEAM EFFORT
SO WE APPRECIATE THE FAMILY
SUPPORT AS WELL. I ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY I THINK
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE
COVERED AND I THINK WOULD BE OF
INTEREST TO OUR PANEL- GIVEN
THE NATURE OF THE LICENSING YOU
PROVIDE SECURITY GUARDS
LOCKSMITHS HOME SECURITY ALARMS
HOW DO YOU BALANCE SOMEBODY
WHO'S- MAY HAVE A CRIMINAL
RECORD THEY'VE SERVE THEIR TIME
THEY'VE COMPLETED CONDITIONS OF
PAROLE. ARE THEY ELIGIBLE TO BE
CONSIDERED IN THESE POSITIONS
HOW DO YOU HANDLE HANDLE THAT.
FACILITATION SURE- HISTORICALLY
THE BEER HAS BEEN VERY
WELCOMING TO APPLICANTS WE
REJECT APPROXIMATELY 2% OF
APPLICANTS PER YEAR- WHAT WE DO
FOR ALL APPLICANTS IS WE RUN
THE SAME BACKGROUND CHECK FOR
EVERYBODY SO YOU SENT AN
APPLICATION YOU DO FINGERPRINTS
WE RECEIVE THE FINGERPRINT
RESPONSES. AND IF YOU DO HAVE A
LESS THAN PERFECT BACKGROUND
YOU GO OVER TO OUR DISCIPLINARY
REVIEW UNIT AND TO WHAT THEY DO
IS THEY TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR
CRIMINAL HISTORY AND THEY LOOK
FOR- MAJOR ISSUES SUCH AS WHAT
IT WAS YOUR ORIGINAL- THE
ORIGINAL CONVICTION FOR.
SERIOUSNESS OF IT THE LENGTH OF
TIME THAT'S PASSED SINCE IT
HAPPENED IN ANY REHABILITATIVE
EFFORTS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
UNDERTAKEN IN THE MEANTIME AND
I CAN'T GIVEN UNIFORM BLANKET
ANSWER BECAUSE WE DO TAKE
EVERY- EVERY INSTANCE THAT THIS
HAPPENS ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS. THERE ARE SEVERAL LEVELS
OF REVIEW FOR EACH ONE. IN I
THINK YOU SHARED ALSO THERE.
THERE'S AN APPEALS PROCESS FOR
SOMEBODY WHO'S TONIGHT IN I
THINK YOU SAID YEAR. KEEP IN
FRONT AND CENTER PROTECTION OF
THE PUBLIC AND CONSUMERS YES WE
DO- WE TEND TO AT THE BUREAU
ERR ON THE SIDE OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION SO WE DO PROJECT A
FEW LICENSEES- WHO THEN APPEAL
TOWARDS OUR DISCIPLINARY REVIEW
COMMITTEE. THAT COMMITTEE HAS
THE CHANCE TO REVIEW THEIR CASE
AT AN IN DEPTH LEVEL THAT WE
ARE UNABLE TO DO SO AND BECAUSE
WE ARE A LITTLE MORE AGGRESSIVE
IN TURNING DOWN THESE THESE- OF
THESE LICENSEES WHO MAY HAVE
HAD A BIT OF A CHECKERED PAST
THE DRC. USUALLY HAS YOU KNOW
THE LUXURY OF TALKING TO THEM
TALKING TO WITNESSES BRINGING
IN- OUTSIDE- CHARACTER
REFERENCES AND SO THEY WILL
OVERTURN US IN SOME INSTANCES
BUT YOU KNOW AT THE PIER ARE
OUR GUIDING PRINCIPLE IS ALWAYS
CONSUMER PROTECTION. THANK YOU
AND THEN RELATED WE ALSO
DISCUSSED FORMER LAW
ENFORCEMENT. OFFICERS WHO SEEK
LICENSING- NOW PRESUMABLY WITH
PRIVATE SECTOR POSITIONS- I
THINK YOU SHARED SOME OF WHAT
YOU CAN LOOK INTO BUT SOME
BARRIERS HUGE YOU CAN'T
NECESSARILY. DETERMINE IF
THERE'S BEEN. COMPLAINTS FOR
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS RELATED TO
CERTAIN INTERACTION THE PUBLIC
IS THAT CORRECT YES THAT IS
CORRECT- WE HAVE ALSO BEER IN
THE- START HAVE COME OUT OF
CERTAIN FORCED. AB DISCIPLINARY
IN THE PAST AND UNFORTUNATELY
IT STATE HAVE NOT BEEN CAN OF
ANY CRIME WE DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO THOSE RECORDS IF IT IS A
DISCIPLINARY ISSUE THAT THEY'VE
HAD WITH THE FORMER EMPLOYER
THAT A- MATTER. AND PORTION WE
DON'T MAKE. TO COMPEL THE FOR
PLOY TO JUST PERSONAL USED TO.
SO THAT IT WILL THAT WE DO WITH
ON YEAH. BUT ONCE THE WHITE BY
YOU. THIRD COMPLAIN. WE SHARE.
WHO HAS STAND TO FIVE A- IF
THEY THINK LICENSE HAS. ACTED
IN A PRO. SURE ONCE OUR LIFE BY
WE TAKE OUR COMPLAIN VERY SEE
IN ANYBODY CAN FILE COMPLAINT.
A SPECTATOR CAN COME CONSIDER
GROUP CAN COME. WE HAVE A CLICK
RIGHT ON OUR HOME PAGE THAT YOU
KNOW IF COME HERE WE IN. 1% OF
OUR COMPLY. AND WE MAKE SURE.
WE HAVE A ROBUST- ARSENAL OF
ACTIONS THAT WE CAN TAKE ON OUR
END ANYWHERE FROM SAY CATIONS
TO FINING TO SUSPENSION. TO OUT
RIGHT- REPLICATION SO WE DO WE
YEAH WE DO TAKE ACTION ON EVERY
COMPLAINT. WHEN I WAS IMPRESSED
WITH YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF THE
OPERATION IN YOUR CONTINUED
COMMITMENT. RISA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU. MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
HE MET THERE GRADUALLY ON YOUR
AND I NO QUESTIONS AT THIS
THANK YOU. OKAY SENATOR. THANK
YOU PRO TEM GROSS FOR ME AS
WELL THE MOVING YOUR NOMINEE OF
THIS REALLY HAPPENS INFECTED IS
THE TIME I'VE BEEN ON THE RULES
CAN THAT I'VE HAD A IN COME UP
FROM THE DISTRICT OFFICE JUST
TO REPORT SOME. FOR CAN THAT IF
TO OUR ABOUT THE RENEWAL OF
THESE EXPOSED FIREARMS PERMITS
AND SOME CONSTITUENCIES HAVING
THE EXPERIENCE OF RECEIVING THE
RENEWAL. A MATTER OF WEEKS OR
IN SOME CASES DAYS BEFORE THE
EXPIRATION. OF THEIR EXISTING
PERMIT AND SINCE IT'S A RENEWAL
POTENTIALLY IMPACTS EMPLOYMENT.
SO I GUESS- MIKE I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS ONE IS ARE YOU
AWARE OF THAT AND NUMBER TWO.
APPARENTLY STE SOME OF THIS MAY
BE THE RESULT OF THE INABILITY
OF. YOUR DEPARTMENT TO IN THE
ACCEPT. RENEWALS ONLINE. SO I
HAVE GOOD NEWS OKAY WE LIED
ABOUT ONLINE NEWS IN THIS
BUILDING RIGHT YEAH ONLY IT'S
NOT FOR A YES SO TO YOUR
QUESTIONS YES I AM AWARE OF IT
THAT IS PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
DRIVER OF CONSIST OF
LEGISLATIVE INCREASE TO THE
BUREAU IS THE EXPOS FARMS AT I
AM VERY HAPPY TO SAY THAT BACK
IN OCTOBER WE PUT THE INITIAL.
ARMS FROM IT COMMA AND EARLIER
JANUARY I WANNA SAY JANUARY
FOURTEENTH POSSIBLY WE PUT
RENEWALS BACK ONLINE SO WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT THAT WILL
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE-
PROCESSING TIMES FOR THAT AND
WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF THEM COME
THROUGH THE ELECTRONIC PROCESS
Q. AND IT'S GONE DOWN FROM. YOU
KNOW EIGHTY SEVEN DAYS ON. TO
LESS THAN FOURTEEN SO WE ARE
ENCOURAGING FOLKS TO GO ONLINE
FOR ALL OF THEIR PROCESS SEES
BECAUSE THE TIME LINES IF YOU
RENEW THROUGH BREEZE. ARE SO
MUCH BETTER THAN PAPER
APPLICATION SO. WELL THANK YOU
THE- GOVERNOR OBVIOUSLY PICKED
THE RIGHT PERSON FOR THE JOB.
THANK YOU BETTER PRO TEM THANK
YOU SENATOR I ONLY HAVE ONE
QUESTION RELATED TO SB SIX OH
NINE- HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT THE CHANGES REQUIRED
AND SB SIX OH NINE THAT WAS
GLACIERS. EXTENDED THE SUNSET
DATE I INCREASE VARIOUS
LICENSEES ARE REQUIRED THE
FUNDS TO BE MERGED IN PROCESSOR
HAVE IS THAT. YES SO THAT WAS
OUR SUNSET BILL YEP AND- THE
PROCESS OF THE FEES WILL BE
MERGED AS OF JULY FIRST TWO ARE
FOR YES HAN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE REQUESTED THAT WE DO IT
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THEIR- FISCAL
YEAR WHICH WERE HAPPY DAY. OKAY
I HAVE LEFT IT WILL MAYBE I
WILL HERE FOR THIS FOR ON LET
ME ASK MEMBER OF THE- WHO ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT I TO COME
FORWARD. GIVE ME YOUR NAME WHO
YOU REPRESENT IF ANYONE OTHER
THAN YOURSELF AND- YOUR
POSITION. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS KATE WALLACE I AM THE
ASSOCIATION MANAGER FOR CAL
STATE GAS. THAT IS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSE SECURITY AGENCIES CARDS
AND ASSOCIATES WE DO REPRESENT
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND LICENSE
OFFICERS IN CALIFORNIA- WE
REALLY APPRECIATE OUR WORKING
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE BUREAU WE SUPPORT THE
SELECTION ONE HUNDRED PERCENT.
OUR PRESIDENT DAVID CHANDLER
COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY BUT HE
DID ASK ME TO OUR VOICES
PERSONAL SUPPORT. ANDWE DO
HAVE OTHER MEMBERS OF OUR BOARD
YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT AS WELL. THANK YOU.
WELCOME I AM THE SECONDS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US. MY NAME IS
MARK MILLER- I'M WITH CAL SAGA
I SIT ON THE BOARD ON LEX
DIRECTOR. AND I WORK FOR
SECURITAS SECURITY SERVICES
USA. WERE THE SECOND LARGEST
SECURITY PROVIDER IN CALIFORNIA
THE SECOND LARGEST PER SECURITY
PROVIDER WORLD WIDE FIFTY THREE
COUNTRIES AND THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES- I
HAVE- HAD THE HONOR OF MEETING
WITH AND WORKING WITH- MISS
ANDERS FOR THE LAST. NINE TO
TEN MONTHS. AND I BELIEVE SHE'S
AN EFFECTIVE A REGULATOR AND
LEADER- WHEN. MISS ADDRESS
FIRST CAME TO THE BUREAU. OF
THESE. APPLICATIONS THAT MISTER
RALPH WAS REFERRING TO. THEY
WERE PAPER CASING WAS SOME
MANUAL. WHICH IS EVERYBODY
KNOWS IS NOT GOOD. AND SO- MISS
ANDREAS WENT TO WORK. ON THIS
PARTICULAR TOPIC SOON AFTER SHE
ARRIVED IN OFFICE AND TODAY. AS
SHE JUST ANNOUNCED I AM HAPPY
TO ANNOUNCE THAT IT'S ALL
ONLINE NOW IT'S ALL AUTOMATED I
WAS LITERALLY. FLYING UP FROM
LA TO DELIVER HANDLE FOR PAPER
APPLICATIONS UNTIL SHE BROUGHT
THIS UP ONLINE SO KUDOS. FOR
THAT- AND SO IT HELPS US AS AN
INDUSTRY IT HELPS PEOPLE GET TO
WORK FASTER AND IT HELPS US
PROVIDE SECURE TO OUR CLIENTS.
UP THE BUREAU ROBUST IN.
DIVISION AND I BELIEVE WITH
THE- BACKGROUND BEING THAT THE
CHEAPEST. WITH THE- HELPS TO
MAKE CASE TWENTY A SAFER. THANK
YOU FOR. THANK YOU. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS. REPRESENT
G. FOR AND CAL SAG ENERGIES ARE
TO PER INTO A LAN ANDRES THE
POINT OF THE FOR SECURITY IN I
HER SO LEADER AND THE SECURE
INDUSTRY WELL FOR MOST PARTNER
AMONG PRIVATE. AND IN TURN
WHICH WILL PROVIDE US CAL I
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE MOVE. I'VE
HAD MANY FOR WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS THAT- HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY PRODUCTIVE WE'VE BEEN
AND SHE HAS A REALLY IN DEPTH
KNOWLEDGE OF THE INDUSTRY AND
WHERE THE PRIVATE SECTOR GOES
THROUGH AND I THINK BEING IN
THIS INDUSTRY I MYSELF TWENTY
YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
BARRIERS AND WE'VE BEEN
STREAMLINING PROCESS BUT IN
TURN I THINK WE'VE BEEN I MEAN.
THE LEVEL OF SECURITY THAT WERE
CALIFORNIA IS DEMANDING IN FACT
IF YOU LOOK ACROSS UNITED
STATES I BELIEVE CALIFORNIA
HOLDS THE HIGH STANDARD FROM
TRAINING AND FROM THE
BACKGROUND. WE HAVE SAID WE
HAVE SEEN SUCH POSITIVE
MOVEMENT THE LAST YEAR I'M I'M
THRILLED SIDE CONTINUE MENEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HI OKAY
GOOD ACTORS MIKE SMITH THE
PRESENT OF ALLIED SECURITY
SERVICES REPRESENT ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND IS IN CAT. OR THE
LARGEST PROVIDER CAL WALL OR TO
ME HERE TO SUPPORT TO LINUX
HER- APPOINTMENT TODAY SHE CAN
GREAT IS MARKET MARKET TALKED
ABOUT- SHE'S BEEN VERY OPEN TO
US AS AN INDUSTRY SHE'S BEEN
VERY COURAGEOUS OPENED HER
STAFF. TO US. THE CONCERN THAT
WE HAVE BEEN IN BUSINESS NOW
FOR THE FOUR IN A CAN SAY IS IN
THE SHOW TIME THAT LENDS BEEN.
OF CALIFORNIA AND IN ARE
INDUSTRY SHE'S BEEN GRAY US RAW
TO YOUR- I PERSONALLY HOLD
EXPOSED. PERMIT TO WE MET WITH
THE CHIEF KNOWN NUMEROUS TIME
OVER THE LAST NINETY MONTHS.
SHE BEEN GREAT ABOUT WORKING
FOR ANY OF THE STUMBLING BLOCKS
IF YOU WILL INCLUDING MOST
RECENTLY GETTING IT BACK ONLINE
SO I THINK HER APPOINTMENT
TODAY WOULD BE WELL SUPPORTED
AND I KNOW IT WOULD BE WELL
SUPPORTED BY THE INDUSTRY. IN
AND I HOPE YOU ALL VOTE FOR HER
CONFIRMATION TODAY SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI
WELCOME. BACK IN SENATOR STAFF
MY NAME IS DEAN GRIFFEY. I'M
HERE TO VOICE MY STRONG SUPPORT
FOR MISS ANDREAS CONFIRMATION
AS CHIEF HAPPY SIS. HAS A
FORMER DIRECTOR DCM VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE QUALITIES
NEEDED. IN IN IN IN IN AN
INDIVIDUAL SUCH AS OR SUCH AN
IMPORTANT DOCUMENT. SANDRA SAYS
HE'S SKILLS TO NOT ONLY DO
THESE DYNAMICALLY. BUT OFTEN
SHOULD LEAD ORGANIZATION TO
REACH THE NEXT LEVEL WITH THE
UTMOST INTACT. MOST
IMPORTANTLY. SHOWS ALL THE
INTENT. OR YOU CAN BROWN TAKING
HER WORK SERIOUS. AWESOME SPEAK
FOR. OF GRAY SPAM TO BE A PIECE.
IN THE ALOHA STATE WHERE SHE
COULD HOME. I YOU ALL TO VOTE
AND FOR OF HER CAR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AFTERNOON CHIU
MEMBERS CARRIED MEN BEHALF OF
THE COUPLE. SO OF LIFE THE BEST.
THE LARGEST PO SO. I THINK IN
THE WERE WE HAVE HAD TO GO
FORTUNE TO GET TO. THE OF
QUICKLY OFTEN SINCE OF. AND CAN
AT TO THE OTHERS. AND WITH OR
SAY IN TERMS OF THE
TRANSPARENCY THE OPEN DOOR THE
COULD QUIT FOR. THE ISSUES AND
ABILITY TO HELP OUR DISCUSS.
AND MOVE AND WE'RE WITH HER
LEADERSHIP AND OF COURSE INCOME
A CALL FOR. THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY MEMBERS OF THE
IN OPPOSITION. OKAY SEEING
NONE- THANK YOU SENATOR OFF FOR
THE MOTION MEN OF SECRETARY
SENATORS BATES MONNING MONNING
AYE ROTH ROTH I WILL WILK AYE
ATKINS A CONSENT OKAY WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OF AN FOR
SENATOR BATES BUT YOU HAVE BEEN
CONFIRMED FOR. I THANK YOU AT
SUNDRESS GRETSCH ELATION. WHICH
NAME. HI THERE. THANKS. THIS
YOU CAN SIT THERE.
YEAH. AND.
MR OPERAS WELCOME I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU KNOW THE DISSENT
APPROACH AND HAD TO DEPART SO
HER LEAVING IS NO REFLECTION ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT SO JUST MAJIDA
ASSURE YOU ON THAT AND COURSE
WERE HERE- HAVE IT FOR A
COMMISSIONER SHIP FOR THE
CALIFORNIA OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT RIGHT NOW LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
ALSO OPENING REMARKS I'M SORRY.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
FIRST IF I MAY TAKE A BRIEF
MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE A FEW
FOLKS. I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
MY BRILLIANT WIFE AND BEST
FRIEND ERICA WHO IS HERE.
TOGETHER WE'RE RAISING TWO
YOUNG BOYS AGES TWO AND FIVE
AND THEY'RE NOT HERE TODAY
BECAUSE THEY ARE TWO AND FIVE.
BUT THEIR PRESENCE LOOMS LARGE
AND EVERYTHING I DO- I'D ALSO
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE SOME OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO TOOK THE
SOUTHWEST BUS UP THIS MORNING.
MY SISTER BELINDA BROTHER LAW
MARTY CAUSING A LOSS CO I EVEN
HAVE A SISTER IN LAW. TERESA
WHO TRAVELED AS FAR AS
CARMICHAEL- FINALLY I'D I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY
COLLEAGUES MAY DO COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE HERE AS WELL AS THOSE
WHO MAY BE WATCHING ON THE
WEBCAST. THANK YOU TO CHAIR
ATKINS AND CENTER MEMBERS OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE I GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR ENGAGEMENT AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE TODAY I ALSO
LIKE TO THINK OF HER NEW SOME
FOR HIS TRUST AND SUPPORT AND
POINTING ME COMMISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT. ALSO AFFECTIONATELY
CALLED DPO. AND I WOULD AGAIN
LIKE TO THANK ALL MY DEAR
COLLEAGUES. THE UNSUNG HEROES
WHO WORK TIRELESSLY EVERY DAY
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
AND OUR LICENSEES. THROUGH THIS
TEAM OF DEDICATED PROFESSIONALS
DDO OVERSEAS THE STATE
FINANCIAL SERVICES INDUSTRY.
FROM BREAKING FROM BANKS TO
CREDIT UNIONS INVESTMENT
ADVISORS AND MANY OTHER
PRODUCTS IN BETWEEN OUR WORK
HELPS TO ENSURE. THE
CALIFORNIANS CAN SAFELY SEND
MONEY TO PEOPLE AND CAUSES A
LOT OF ACCESS CAPITAL TO MEET
SHORT TERM NEEDS AND LONG TERM
DREAMS. GREW THEIR MONEY AND
SAFE INVESTMENT VEHICLES AND
ENGAGE AND NUMEROUS OTHER
FINANCIAL ACTIVITIES.
CALIFORNIA IS A WORLD CLASS
ECONOMY DESERVING OF A WORLD
CLASS FINANCIAL REGULATOR I AM
HUMBLED AND THRILLED TO PLAY A
ROLE IN FULFILLING THAT VISION.
OVER THE LAST DECADE CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES HAVE LED THE COUNTRY
PERHAPS EVEN THE WORLD IN
FINANCIAL SERVICES INNOVATION.
FOR MOBILE PAYMENTS ONLINE
LOANS TO CRYPTO CURRENCIES AND
INVESTMENT ROBO ADVISORS.
CALIFORNIA COMPANIES HAVE BLAZE
NEW BUSINESS MODELS NEW
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCES. AND
ULTIMATELY IN THE STATUS QUO.
THESE CHANGES HOLD BOTH PROMISE
AND PERIL AND IT IS MY GOAL IS
COMMISSIONER OF THIS DEPARTMENT
TO STRIKE A SENSIBLE BALANCE.
BETWEEN CONSUMER PROTECTIONS ON
THE ONE HAND WHICH PRESERVE THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR STATE
FINANCIAL ECOSYSTEM. AND
RESPONSIBLE TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATION IN FINANCIAL
SERVICES WHICH MAY INCREASE
ACCESS TO QUALITY AND
AFFORDABLE FINANCIAL PRODUCTS.
OF COURSE NO GOAL OF THIS
MAGNITUDE CAN BE ACHIEVED BY
ONE PERSON WHICH IS WHY I ALSO
PLAN TO FOCUS ON HIRING AND
TRAINING STAFF FOR OPTIMAL
RESULTS. THE DEPARTMENT'S
GREATEST ASSET IS ITS MISSION
COMMITTED TO STAFF AND I HOPE
WE CAN BUILD ON THE ASSET TO
ATTRACT TOMORROW'S LEADERS. AND
BECAUSE WE ARE CALIFORNIA HOME
OF THE MOST DIVERSE POPULATION
OF THE COUNTRY. I'M COMMITTED
TO PROMOTING A CULTURE THAT
VALUES DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION.
WHICH HAS LONG BEEN A VALUE
DEEPLY IN. ORTON TO ME
PERSONALLY AGAIN I GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
SHARE MY VISION AND THOUGHTS
AND I WILL GLADLY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE HOUSE.
THANK YOU CENTER MINING THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IN A WELCOME
MR HOURS CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT I ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY AND-
COVER TO BRED TO THE ISSUES I
THINK WHEN THAT MIGHT BE OF
INTEREST TO THE PANEL- IS SAY
AREA OF. CANNABIS BANKING THIS
NEW INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
LEGALIZED INDUSTRY AND SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES WITH FEDERAL
RULES AND MAYBE A OVER VIEW OF
HOW YOU'RE APPROACHING THAT TO
THE EXTENT IT FALLS WITHIN YEAR
ARENA OF REGULATION THANK YOU
SIR APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING. FOR A LITTLE
BIT OF CONTEXT I WOULD SAY. ALL
OF OUR LICENSEE BANKS AND
CREDIT UNIONS UNDERSTANDS THE-
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES POSED BY.
AND THE CASH INTENSIVE
INDUSTRY- AND THE CANNABIS
RELATED BUSINESSES AND THERE
IS. GENERALLY ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
AND INTEREST IN HELPING TO.
MEDICAID SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THAT CASH INTENSIVE
INDUSTRY. AS YOU KNOW OF COURSE
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
OVERLAY SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
PROBLEM TO ALL OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND SORE
LICENSEES ARE. IN A IN A BIT OF
A BIND IT BECAUSE THEY ARE
SOMETIMES AT A LOSS WITH HOW TO
RESOLVE THE- LEGALITY AT THE
STATE LEVEL WITH THE CONTINUED
ILLEGALITY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE OF
DEPARTMENT. WE HAVE BEEN DOINGFOR THE LAST COUPLE MONTHS AND
WHAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO IS
TO MEET WITH OUR LICENSEES WHO
ARE EITHER CURRENTLY BANKING
CANNABIS RELATED BUSINESSES OR
WHO MAY BE INTERESTED AND
FORMALIZING PROGRAMS AROUND
CANNABIS RELATED BUSINESSES.
AND WERE SEEKING TO PROVIDE AS
MUCH CLARITY AS POSSIBLE AROUND
OUR EXPECTATIONS- AS THEIR
STATE REGULATOR. WE ARE. CLEAR
A FINE FOR OUR LICENSE. THAT
BUT- WILL MANCE. INTERFERE GET
IN THE WAY OF ANY BUSINESS
PLANS THAT THEY MAY HAVE SOLELY
BECAUSE THEY'RE SEEKING TO.
PROVIDE SERVICES TO CANNABIS
RELATED BUSINESSES- BACK IN
OCTOBER THE DEPARTMENT ISSUED
SOME GUIDANCE TO. BANKS AND
CREDIT UNIONS LAYING OUT THE
DEPARTMENTS EXPECTATIONS- WHEN
WE GO INTO EXAM IN AN
INSTITUTION THAT IS TOUCHING
CANNABIS RELATED BUSINESSES.
ADDITIONALLY WE'VE- WE'VE
CONVENED A COUPLE OF DEPOSITORY
INSTITUTIONS AND A CANNABIS
WORKING GROUP OF THE FIRST
CONVENING WAS. NOVEMBER LATE
NOVEMBER. AND WE BROUGHT
TOGETHER LEADERSHIP FROM A
HANDFUL OF DIFFERENT BANKS AND
CREDIT UNIONS TO DISCUSS. WHAT
ADDITIONAL PAIN POINTS- THEY'RE
FACING AND THE WAYSIN WHICH
THE DEPARTMENT BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT CAN POTENTIALLY
PROVIDE GREATER CLARITY AND
COMFORT TO THOSE BANKS- THOSE
BANKS SEE SWEETS AND- BOARDS OF
DIRECTORS SO WE WILL CONTINUE
ALONG THAT PATH AND WILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE AS MUCH.
CLARITY AS POSSIBLE TO THOSE
INSTITUTIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I ALSO WANT TO WELCOME
YOUR FAMILY IN COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR SUPPORT AND- NO THIS IS A
TEAM EFFORT SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR I'M
I'M GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR MONEY MINING. CENTER ROTH.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR
CONGRATULATIONS COMMISSION. SO
JUST FOLLOWING ON MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS ABOUT BANKING DO YOU-
HAVE ANY PARTICULAR CONCERNS
ABOUT A LOCAL AGENCIES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- ENTERING INTO THE
BANKING ENVIRONMENT. GIVEN THE
BILL THAT WAS RECENTLY PASSED.
BUT MEETING TAKE A STEP BACK
AND- AGAIN FOR PROVIDE A LITTLE
MORE CONTEXT IN THAT ARENA. WE
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
MEETING WITH. VARIOUS
REPRESENTATIVES OF SOME OF THE
SOME OF THE CITIES THAT MIGHT
BE INTERESTED IN PURSUING A
PUBLIC BANK CHARTER AS AS AN
OPTION. AND THE MESSAGE SHOULD
THAT WE HAVE BEEN THE
FUNDAMENTAL MESSAGE THAT WE
HAVE BEEN REAL LANE TO THOSE
PROSPECTIVE APPLICANTS IS THAT
ANY SUCH APPLICATION WILL BE
REVIEWED ACCORDING TO THE SAME
STANDARDS THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD APPLY TO ANY OTHER.
FORMATION GROUP- AND THESE ARE
STRINGENT STANDARDS WE'RE GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT THINGS LIKE.
CAPITAL ADEQUACY RATIOS WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING TO THE
CHARACTER AND OVERALL
EXPERIENCE OF THE PROPOSED
INSTITUTIONS MANAGEMENT BOARDS
OF DIRECTORS. SO WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS. PROSPECTIVE CITIES THAT
MAYBE LOOKING TO FORM A PUBLIC
BANK. HAVE TO MEET HIGH
EXPECTATIONS. THEY ALSO HAVE TO
MEET WITH FAIRLY STRINGENT
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE NEW
PUBLIC BANK LAW INCLUDING- FDIC
INSURANCE- WHICH WHICH IS NO
SMALL FEAT- AND- AND THEY WOULD
HAVE TO SECURE A FEASIBILITY
STUDY SHOWING THAT- SHOWING
THAT THEIR BUSINESS PLAN CAN
SUCCEED OVER THE LONG TERM. I
FRANKLY DON'T KNOW THAT I HAVE.
ENOUGH INFORMATION TO FORM AN
INDEPENDENT OPINION AS TO
WHETHER THIS IS A GOOD THIN
WHETHER THIS IS A BAD THING
FRANKLY I DON'T KNOW THAT MY
OPINION ON THE MATTER IS ALL
THAT MATERIAL WHAT I WOULD SAY
IS. I THINK SOME OF THOSE
PROSPECTIVE INSTITUTIONS- WE'LL
HAVE TO CLEAR OF THE FAIRLY
HIGH BAR. HOW DID THE- HER
PENSION. FACTOR INTO CAPITAL
AND LIQUIDITY REQUIREMENTS FOR.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO SEEK TO
FORM OF PUBLIC BANK. I THINK
THAT I THINK THAT HAS A
FANTASTIC QUESTION AND THE
SHORT ANSWER IS. I DON'T
EXACTLY KNOW BECAUSE THAT'S
GOING TO BE ON THE THAT WILL BE
LARGELY IN THE ONUS OF THE
LOCAL. THE LOCAL GOVERNING BODY
HI THE LOCAL GOVERNING BODY
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE TO FIGURING
OUT THEIR THEIR OUTSTANDING
PENSION OBLIGATIONS AND HOW
BEST TO BALANCE THOSE
OUTSTANDING LIABILITIES AGAINST
SOME OF THE CAPITAL
REQUIREMENTS ON WITH RESPECT TO
PUBLIC THANK APPLICATION. SO
THE SHORT ANSWER IS. IT'S HARD
TO SAY WITH GREAT SPECIFICITY
BUT IT'S ALSO HARD TO IMAGINE
THAT OUTSTANDING PENSION
OBLIGATIONS WOULD. MAKE IT EASY
FOR PROSPECTIVE APPLICANTS TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS ADEQUATE
CAPITAL RESERVED FOR A FOR A
NEW BANK CHARTER WILL NOT NOT
BEING AN ACCOUNTANT TO AS SOON.
UNFUNDED LIABILITIES HAVE TO BE
CARRIED ON A BALLOT SHEET
SOMEWHERE- AND THAT SORT OF
BALANCE SHEET FINANCIAL
STATEMENT AS SAID LIABILITY
ANALYSIS. HAS TO BE PERFORMED
BY SOMEONE IN DETERMINING AS
SOON AS- VIABILITY OF THE
PROPOSED ENTITY CORRECT. THAT'S
CORRECT AND THAT WOULD ALL FEED
INTO. THE PROPOSED ENTITIES
BUSINESS PLAN WHICH IS A
SUBSTANTIAL PART OF THE
APPLICATION ITSELF AND ONE OF
THE ONE OF THE CRITICAL FACTORS
THE DEPARTMENT ASSESSES WHEN
REVIEWING A NEW APPLICATION FOR
BANK CHARTER IS. THE STRENGTH
OF THE BUSINESS PLAN AND THE
LIKELIHOOD OF SUCCESS OVER THE
LONG HAUL AS REFLECTEDIN THAT
BUSINESS PLAN. FASCINATING
SPERM CERTAIN WILL BE HAVING
MORE CONVERSATIONS BOTH IN AND
OUT OF THIS BUILDING ON THE
SUBJECT BUT THANK YOU FOR BEING
WILLING TO SERVE
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN ON A MOVE
THE- A CONFIRMATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
MISTER FISHER. THANK YOU CENTER
ROTH I'M SORRY WE DO NOT HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET TOGETHER
AND I SAID I DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS. QUESTION NUMBER ONE
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE POWERS
OF YOUR DEPARTMENT- AND IT
LOOKS LIKE AS A BE QUITE BROAD.
I'M JUST WONDERING IF YOU HAVE
A- FILLED FOR THE EMPLOYMENT
WHAT THE TIME LINE IS FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT. AND
THEN WE'LL HOW- WELL IT IN AND
TAX FEES ON EXISTING ENTITIES
LIKE- STATE CHARTERED BANKS AND
CREDIT UNIONS. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY- SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES. THE WHAT I WOULD SAY
LET ME START WITH RESPECT TO
THE FEES. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL SHOULD HAVE NO IMPACT
NO MATERIAL IMPACT ON THE FEES
OF EXISTING LICENSEES NOW. THE
MAJOR CABBIE OUT THERE OF
COURSE IS THAT FEES AND
ASSESSMENTS DO NATURALLY GO UP
OVER TIME THINGS- ACOSTA DO GO
UP BUT WITH RESPECT TO THE
INCREMENTAL COSTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND THE
IMPACT ON EXISTING LICENSEES
THERE SHOULD BE NO MATERIAL
IMPACT AND- WE HAVE WE HAVE
ALREADY BEEN MEETING WITH- WITH
SOME OF OUR INCOME AND
LICENSEES. IF OF COURSE BEEN
ASKING THIS QUESTION AMONG
OTHERS AND WE HAVE- WE HAVE
CONVEYED AS MUCH I HOPE THE
TWO- TO THOSE INCOME THAT
LICENSEES. THE AT WITH RESPECT
TO YOUR FIRST QUESTION I
APOLOGIZE WOULD YOU PERJURE
GATE IT. YOUR BRA THE POWER SO.
WHAT IT WHAT IS LOOKING TO LOOK
LIKE IN IN TERMS OF LIKE A TIME
LINE FOR IMPLEMENTATION TO
BRING IT TO FRUITION. JUST
GENERAL QUESTIONS- GENERALLY
SPEAKING. WE EXPECT TO WE
EXPECT TO SPEND MUCH OF THE
FIRST YEAR STAFFING UP SOME OF
THE- SOME OF THE NEWER
FUNCTIONS SO FOR EXAMPLE. SOME
OF THE SOME OF THE PROPOSED
OFFICES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
FOCUSED ON EDUCATIONAL EFFORTS
WE WANT TO START STAFFING OP
THE LEADERS OF THOSE FUNCTIONS
WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR SIMILARLY
WITH RESPECT TO THE OFFICE OF
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION. WE WANT
TO GET STARTED STAFFING UP THAT
OFFICE WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR SO
I WOULD SEE WHAT THEY WITHIN
THE FIRST YEAR. THE MARKERS OF
SUCCESS ARE GOING THE WEATHER
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PLAN AND-
LEADERSHIP FOR SOME THOSE
FUNCTIONS. HERE TO I THINK
THAT'S WHERE WE CAN REALLY
START TO SEE SOME OF THE FRUITS
OF LABOR WE TO. ENGAGEMENT WITH.
TECHNO STAKEHOLDERS WE HOPE
START TO DEVELOP A BETTER SENSE
HOW. TO APPROACH SOME OF.
EMERGING PRODUCTS AND SO. AND
WE HOPE TO. WE HOPE. ENGAGE
DEEPLY WITH SOME OF THE- SOME
OF THE MORE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THAT WE LOOK TO
PROTECT INCLUDING VETERANS NEW
AMERICANS AND THE ELDERLY- I
THINK. I THINK ALL IN THE
PROPOSAL AS WE HAVE
CONTEMPLATED SHOULD BE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD AND THAT'S THAT'S
PRIMARILY A FUNCTION OF
STAFFING- WE LOOKED AT THE AT
THE NUMBERS AND- WE LOOKED AT
THE NUMBERS OF INCREMENTAL
HIRES AS WEALTHIEST HISTORICAL
ATTRITION RATES. AND WE THINK
WE CAN COMFORTABLY. BUILD UP
THE NEW DEPARTMENT OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD AND WELL INTO THE
FUTURE OF COURSE A GOOD. MY
FINAL QUESTION JUST CURIOUS ON
THE STATUS OF THE DEPARTMENTS
RULE MAKING INITIATIVES IN
PARTICULAR- WINDOWS HE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT EXPECT THAT THE RULES
FOR SB TWELVE THIRTY FIVE
RELATED TO COMMERCIAL FINANCE
DISCLOSURES AND AGENTS OF
FINANCIAL. FINANCIAL PROTECTION
LAW. COME TO FRUITION. TWELVE
THIRTY FIVE WE JUST WRITE THAT
DOWN TWELVE THIRTY FIVE IS WELL
UNDER WAY- I AM HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP WITH SPECIFIC DETAILS BUT I
DO BELIEVE THAT WE'RE ON TRACK
TO. IMPLEMENT A TWELVE THIRTY
FIVE- BY END OF TWENTY TWENTY
OR BY BY EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- WE DID- FOR A BIT OF
CONTEXT WE DID PUT OUT. A
REQUEST FOR BID ON- USER
TESTING OF THE NEW DISCLOSURES
WE DID NOT RECEIVE ANY BIDS
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET THAT
SLOW STAND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH WITH THE RULE
MAKING AS AS PLANNED. GREAT AB
PRECIADO ST STE. AT THIS IF
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO COME UP
AND SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND COME
UP TO THE MIKE A TO OUR LAST-
NAME ORGANIZATION IF YOU WANNA
SAY SOMETHING BRIEFLY THAT'S
ENCOURAGE AS LONG AS IT'S BRIEF.
CAN WE HAVE A WINNER. RIGHT THE
RICO. HELLO MY NAME IS SERGEANT
DARKER AND THE GENERAL COUNSEL
OF RENEWED FINANCIAL AND I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE CONFIRMATION AN
MANY AS COMMISSIONER OF THE
GPO- MANNY'S BACKGROUND
COMBINES TWO PERSPECTIVES I
THINK ARE ESSENTIAL TO THE ROLE
DVL OMMISSIONER STRONG BELIEF
IN THE PERSON'S FOR ENFORCEMENT
OF CONSUMER PROTECTION LAWS AND
CONSISTENT SUPPORT FOR BUSINESS
INNOVATION GROWTH. HAVING
WORKED CLOSELY WITH HIM IN THE
PAST I CAN ALSO SPEAK HIS
ABILITY TOWARD VERY
PRODUCTIVELY WITH PEOPLE
REPRESENTING A WIDE RANGE OF
BACKGROUNDS OF POINTS OF VIEW.
AS CALIFORNIA LAW TO THE UPON
OUR LAST OF ROBUST GROWTH.
THERE'S NO ONE I CAN THINK HIS
MORE CABLE. OF BOUNCE OUR NEED
FOR AN INNOVATIVE BUSINESS
SECTOR WITH OUR NEED FOR SO
GETS FOR THOSE REASONS I'M A
PROUD I'M PROUD TO ENDORSE HIS
CONFIRMATION FOR A COMMISSIONER
WHOLEHEARTEDLY THANK YOU. SURE
MEMBERS RJ SAID ABOUT THIS ON
BEHALF ELECTRONIC TRANSACTIONS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THE CONFIRMATION THANK YOU.
PARK LASTING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BANKING
NETWORK- WITHIN TWO
COMMISSIONER IS A THOUGHTFUL
ACCESSIBLE AND EMINENTLY
QUALIFIED WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONFIRM HIM TODAY THANK YOU.
YOU. MISTER CHAIR AND CENTERS
KEVIN GOLD OF THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION WE ALSO
SUPPORT MISTER ALBERT ALVAREZ'S
CONFIRMATION WE THINK HE'S WELL
QUALIFIED FOR THE POSITION AND
WE ASK YOU TO MOVE THEM FORWARD
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ALEX TOURISM WE HAVE
SQUARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
REPORT. PROPER WILL SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
HERE IN SUPPORT. SHE REMEMBERS
MY CONFUSING HERE ON BEHALF OF
OPPORTUNE OF THE LARGEST.
ORIGINATOR OF RESPONSIBLE
SMALLER LOANS IN THE STATE THAT
WE WORKED A MISTER ALVAREZ IN
MANY CONTEXTS OVER MANY YEARS
UNIQUELY QUALIFIED FOR THIS
POSITION THANK YOU WE URGE IS
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU SIR.
THE ONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
BEFORE YOU WE DO THAT CENTER
BATES ARE THERE QUESTIONS YOU'D
LIKE TO ASK. RELATED. YEAH OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU WAS A WE HAVE A
FOR ROTH. SENATE BATES. MY BAY
I'D MY MINING I ROTH ROSS I
WILL HI WILK I. FOUR ZERO FOUR
ZERO AND YOU ARE CONGRATULATE.
QUIRK OF YOU CAN LIFT THE CALL
ON ONE BE. I SUSPECT BATES.
BAITS ARE. FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO
NINE CONFIRMED. YEAH SO. YEAH.
MEETING ADJOURNED.